[Music]
community building is something that is
ingrained in me
uh it is something that i went to school
for and it's something that i also want
to always see that you do not feel left
out
i remember back in high school i was
class president and
i didn't have said a click to be a part
of but i knew
everyone and everyone knew me and that
is where i want to make sure that you
realize
i think of maya angelou's quote who says
people may forget what you
did people will forget what you said but
they will never forget how you made them
feel
she doesn't think of herself alone to
think of the whole
community so whatever she can do to help
students co-workers she's there
with the pandemic and with everything it
was
it was such a difficulty so i
really think that you know natalie
with all the work she did deserves this
award
and i want you to know that whenever i'm
a part of your community or whether i'm
a part of your office or a part of your
committee
the aura and the feeling is of warmth
and that it is of a place where
everyone is seen and heard and so when
it comes to
mit as a whole when i put mit and
community next to each other
it goes back to martin luther king's
speech where he says america all i could
say is
be true to what you said on paper so we
cannot act in a performative way
whenever we see
injustice anywhere we cannot act in
terms of when it's martin luther king
day that is when we remember that there
is injustice everywhere
we cannot be a an actor of change we
have to actually
do the change be the change live the
change and see the change